I'm quite excited about this interview
because I feel like you've had access to
more prime ministers in a more intimate
way possibly than anyone I've ever
interviewed if you think about it right
yeah no that's right I was the first one
and to go into number 10 as the official
photographer
um and with that I then stayed on to do
four so uh Cameron May Boris and Liz
truss yeah so
there is no one else that's photographed
it or documented it um for that period
of time
um and now it's now it's happened
they've continued on with the uh with
the photographers that are there today
so it's good it's all set up I've had a
lot of access
all day out of the room or I could
probably count on one hand when I was
asked to leave the room and it was
either one because there was spies that
had come in from MI5 or six or whatever
obviously so for obvious reasons
um two when when they phoned a queen
because we obviously weren't allowed in
there or three or without a private
issue that they wanted to sort out at
the time you know they do have their own
lives that they need to sort out as well
so but I would say definitely on one
hand
um that I was asked to leave and I was
very lucky I mean it was it was a
fantastic opportunity where I had free
reign to go
um in all the meetings whether it was
the covid meetings brexit meetings and
towards the end obviously all the
Ukraine meetings that were being held a
majority of the time insecure tight
secure rooms with only very few of us in
there that perhaps would know that was
coming down the track if you had to pick
out like one pinch yourself moment when
you were like I actually can't believe
this is happening
um
yeah it's a question is how it's quite a
lot there's a there's a couple of them
once really the first time I ever
thought that was when Cameron left and
uh Theresa May took over because what
happens is you they they're clapped out
uh you do the pictures there's quite a
lot of emotion going around with the
staff because that you know they've been
working for the Prime Minister for so
long so there's a few tears clapping him
out the family are usually with him him
and his children he goes out and then 30
minutes later Theresa May comes in and
they're clapping her in and it's all of
a sudden the Expressions have changed
and it's smiling and like you say it is
pretty brutal and it is from my role I
can't at all get attached to it you just
have to keep on going stay focused and
and then you start again you're in with
the new one the the Theresa May starts
and then the reshuffle starts and it all
happens in one day you start the day
with say David Cameron at eight o'clock
doing his briefing by the evening
um Theresa May is forming a cabinet and
at that point I did think gosh it can't
get any any bet in this in the sense of
historic moments but then the last year
or so has been pretty turbulent and and
every day was different every day it was
just off it was off diary and things
were happening and flying around and
yeah yeah the last three days but when
Boris resigned was was quite tough yeah
it's interesting hear me because I kind
of feel I don't get the same access but
out on Downing Street and you you start
off with one person that elected and
then a couple of hours later so someone
else you're like what's going on it was
truly amazing yeah yeah um let's let's
talk through some of the moments I want
to use some of the photos that you've
taken to do it as well
um here you go
call me Dave yeah exactly yeah I do yeah
this was a very very old one on Pancake
Day over at his house in West London
where he decided to make us all pancakes
and um purely quite often is that it was
quite he was quite good on the stove he
would quite often cook odd random things
if we were all around there doing stuff
and this was just one of those moments
where he goes right it's Pancake Day
everyone and um and and away he went
sort of thing and the you told me when
we spoke before the interview that you
were there for the Coalition talks
between the libs yeah that's right the
conservatives which I'm kind of
fascinated by how was that so that was
2010 and we were over in Port Collins
house then and um
it was it was very stop start stop start
stop start oh it's coming close it's
coming close and then there was a lot of
um a lot of pizzas being delivered
ordered in the middle of the night and
stuff like that so they get honest well
as they seem to David Cameron and Nick
Clerk or from from the uh the parts that
I photographed especially in that
Coalition and into the early years of
number 10 then yeah they were they were
very good I remember
um the first time that David Cameron and
Nick clay walked into the cabinet room
together and um and David Cameron did
say to Nick Club we're going to do some
amazing things in this room and they and
they both smiled in an agreement of
um yes we've made it let's make it work
sort of thing and then you went from
David Cameron to Theresa May I mean I
can't really imagine you know a greater
sort of Personality contrast than these
two issues
um doing her paperwork studious that's
right we were on the flights there
because usually what happens is that um
when the Prime Minister gets in they
then go and tour Scotland Wales and
Northern Ireland and this was one of
those days I remember I think we on our
way to see Nicholas sturgeon from
remember rightly
and uh and Teresa Teresa was lovely to
work for and and in some ways
um you knew where you were um she had a
lovely personality and and was there to
get on with the job rather than worry
about anything else that what we were
doing and things like that so a lot of
stuff which Theresa was at work very
natural
um as opposed to I didn't you know as
opposed to campaigning or doing odd bit
beats I interviewed Teresa quite a few
times and I've always found her like you
say like very diligent but she she
didn't do small talk at all was she like
that with you behind the scenes or not I
mean every now and again yes not not so
much but every now and again you have to
spend a lot of time with them to have
the small talk if it's if it's small
episodes such as going to Scotland and
back the days are so busy that there's
not much um small talk to be had it's
usually on the foreign trips the Summits
or the
um you know or the various other sort of
leader trips that you'd go and see
um
she she would have a laugh with you she
would have a joke with you there was one
picture I took of her where she's she's
um she's making everyone laugh when
she's leaning on a photocopier um and
she would come out with little
one-liners that would make people laugh
and it would just be that that moment of
surprise that she would give to everyone
because it wasn't expected yeah that
just made her just um relax and things
like that and there's another classic
one she used to do the morning rounds as
you know of at conference and um she's
in in the studio being interviewed for a
radio station and there's a picture of
her and everyone's in stitches
um because she's been she said something
very sarky to um to to the to the
interview a journalist at the time and
you had to be on your garden with the
others you expected it with retrievement
it was so limited that when it did
happen it was very funny yeah and then
obviously Boris Johnson said
uh very different
um person like Hugo he's on a plane this
kind of feels like a classic Boris
Johnson picture yeah that's right that's
when we were um
we were doing a tour off to uh some
military bases I think to go and see the
Ukraine uh soldiers being trained by the
Brits and uh they just said you know
that he was tied on obviously and and
said you know he was offered a seat at
the back to have a look and at which
point he did I think at which point he'd
resigned by then anyway
um and he was just waiting for the
period
um for the for the new one to take over
so it would have been between the July
and September of that year
um but this wasn't him doing a trick he
just went to have a look and you'd go
and join him but he would have no qualms
about you going to join him on on the
back there he wouldn't think it was
unusual like why are you taking a
picture he would actually sort of
understand what we did you know uh I
want to talk about this picture because
this is the moment that Boris Johnson
read Rishi Cena explosive Nation letter
that's pretty much in that moment yeah
it's around that secret and this has
never been seen before
um
no not on the not in television I don't
think no no not exactly so like this is
the moment where I think this is where
he's starting to say right we can we can
still do this how how did he react
because you know for many people who
thought this is the moment the game's up
right his Chancellor's gone
um well when you're in the room
um you're not really focused too much on
what's been said and what's going on
because you're you're waiting for the
moment to happen but Boris always came
back always always even when he it was
down and out he always came back um one
thing I would say about him and David
Cameron that when things were would
um
what seemed to be sort of down and not
and not on his side they sort of
relished on the fight and it was gave
him more energy if letting nothing less
you know and they and they therefore
took that and they sort of as I guess
you could say got the ball and run with
it a lot of the time it's very rare that
I'd see him down and out what were the
times that you did see him down
um
or I'd have to write those on a postcard
and send them to I can't remember I mean
is this is this one of them he looks
pretty done and out here no I think this
is just him having a serious
conversation on on his last day in
office yeah and this is the last day in
office he's there with Simon case of
course another person who's been in the
headlines an awful lot recently the head
of the sort of service
um and watching and watching people
getting ready for him to deliver his
speech yeah how was he on this day
um surprisingly well actually I I was
quite surprised I thought there would be
a bit more downbeat about it I mean
don't get me wrong no one was rolling
around laughing but it was business as
usual and this is what we've got to do
and this is where we are at and you know
this is what's happened would it
surprise you if you went for another run
at it then if you came back cool
I don't know I mean I thought what was
quite
tell him the other day was when there
was pictures of him leaving his house in
his old car obviously the dog was was in
the front and he was waving and things
like that and I looked at those pictures
and it reminded me so much of the old
days of when he was mayor and he was out
campaigning and it was like one I was
surprised he was driving because usually
the cops are driving him around and
stuff
um but that's Boris he wanted to do it
so he's obviously wants to do it but it
just reminded me so much of
of the old days that's interesting just
a picture alone you know the moving
footage of like the photographers and
the film crews around him and but he
wasn't phased by it when the damn waving
it's it's all it's no problem gang don't
worry we're just on our way out to you
know go out for lunch or whatever and it
it just had that element of yeah made
you think
yeah I'll pause for a minute thinking oh
interesting it's it's like the old days
and let's see where there we go again
um this is a very different image
obviously this is during covert
yes exactly and um
it was tough um Kobe for everyone
obviously for obvious reasons and um
but inside inside work it was uh news
was filtering through all the time of
what was going on and this would have
been one of those moments where news was
sort of breaking that
um you know whatever trouble was
happening around the country at the time
um
you know and he worked hard had it you
know everyone was in there for long
times periods a day because it was such
a moving moving issue and you obviously
famously
took a lot of the pictures
that were used as evidence in party game
right in the inquiry
I don't know if you can give us any
sense about what was actually going on
in number 10 during that time
well I wasn't sure I was only um partial
to that the one in the cabinet room so
it's not you know I was asked by the
inquiry to hand over those images of um
of the cabinet room is which is what I
did so from the rest of it
yeah it's difficult you can comment if
you know didn't have the official
photographer there exactly yeah yeah
yeah yeah that makes sense
um definitely
um let's have a little look at I think
we've got Boris Johnson and rishi's
sunak
uh or was she seen that because I'm
quite interested in the relationship
between the two men you obviously saw
them you didn't work for a she say night
but you saw him working for Boris
Johnson's Chancellor did they get on
what was it like yeah yeah they did get
on
um and there's pictures of them together
getting on very well indeed you know
um when they've been appointed and at
conferences
um and in meetings etc etc I mean this
one was just taken at conference where
he's preparing to do his conference
speech
um as Chancellor I believe
um and he was um
and and I still do bits and pieces with
him today and on the political front but
um
and he's he's easy easy to photograph uh
that's totally natural picture in fact I
think I'm sort of knelt down by a chair
so it's not like I'm standing up and
he's a parent that I'm because he's
trying to make himself look taller in
pictures I'm just interested
I've never witnessed um I only do that
because I I tend that's the angles I
tend to like very nicely
yeah I've never seen any evidence of any
props being used to to make anyone in
politics taller okay I tell you Ruth
Davidson did it once for me in uh in uh
in Scotland with her and David Cameron
she stood on a car battery I think which
she uh which is what's sent me the
picture of the other day
then you also
periods um
um there she is preparing to resign I
think that is or no that was when the
chancellor resigned oh when she sat
consequencing which must have been a
difficult day for her how was she on
that day
um that I mean it's my job is to blend
in and just to just to document what's
in front of in front of me it's not for
me to to judge how they are how they
know there's so much going on they've
got so much
um so many other issues
um as you can see that was like minutes
to spare as you can see by the headline
um on the television there I think she
was due on at 2 30 it's 2 it's 2 29.
um it's you know it's these are tense
moments and you're there to document
these tense moments not there to I'm
definitely not there to judge the
moments because
um with the situations that I've been in
um
I'd spend my life being a judge I had a
judge in the moment you know you you
pretty much blend in you get on with it
it's been extraordinary looking at the
pictures to realize what a roller
coaster period you've done this over
um those pictures of David Cameron feel
like they're from another world and then
you look at stuff like this and you're
like wow this was so intense at the time
yeah do you feel that the experience
that you've had has given you more or
less confidence in the way our country's
run
uh now you're talking politics right
it's a different thing that's a
different thing um but you know I'm not
here to I'm not here to comment about
how the country is running no it's not
right thanks very much for being on the
programs we're really interesting and to
look at some of the images as well
extraordinary brilliant